everyone believes in the American dream
until it comes true when I was sleeping
on the gym floor I was the underdog you
know my clients were all like oh good
for you you know you're going after your
dream and they'd see my blanket and my
pillow in the corner of the gym and they
knew I was sleeping there and then
within 9 months I had hired people and I
had a manager and I remember I walked in
the lobby and the same people were like
ah boss man's here oh you're you're not
too good for us now right and I remember
being so Jarred by the experience and I
was like you guys rooted for me and now
I did what you said you were Roo for me
to do and that was when I realized that
people want you to do well but not
better than them